understand you recently had minor
surgery i did i uh i had lasik i had my
eyes uh lasik uh lasik
um and common common surgery yeah it is
but it's like i don't know if i would
have that surgery i think i had it cause
like that word lasik is so like strong
and clear and precise it just sounds
sharp do you know like i don't know if i
would have that surgery if they were
like it's a very common procedure it's
minorly invasive it's called mulching
and what we do is we mulch your eye
my buddy birchman does it
it sounds like they're just taking fists
and just grinding them in there that's
not good but it worked out all right you
you're seeing well yeah although i kind
of like i kind of miss wearing glasses
so i'm hoping my eyes deteriorate so i
can put it back
first time i've ever heard anyone ever
say that well everybody hates themselves
differently
i hope my eyes deteriorate real soon
let's talk about kroll show a lot of
terrific characters on kroll's show uh
let's talk about uh some of the
characters uh the aspen character yes uh
so i do a bit with uh my friend john
daly called uh rich dix um
and uh he plays a guy named uh
wendy shawn and
that his family owns glass
and my character is aspen bruckenheimer
and uh we started an instagram account
for them
um and they're just rich guys that do
horrible they're just the worst people
they're just like rich dudes who've
never worked a day in their lives and
like all the masculinity and everything
has just been sort of like leisured out
of them
um and they just leave a trail of
destruction everywhere they go with no
consequences and we we have a a picture
here of aspen bruckheimer yeah and
what's what's happened here so this is
the the
the the the caption on it is something
like
uh oh aspen shouldn't be riding a boat
oops
he doesn't care he doesn't care he'll
get another one
exactly uh you do a sketch that i really
love called pub liz
pub lizzity publicity yes publicity and
uh i can never pronounce it but it's
basically uh you and uh jenny slate and
jenny slate play publicists uh who have
their own reality show and uh you're
terrible terrible publicists yeah we're
the worst yeah we're both named liz and
uh she's pretty liz and i'm just liz and
you'll see why shortly and um and yeah
and we have this and we're trying to
pitch new clients always but we make
everything worse i think that seems to
be the common theme is that we make
everything all my characters make
everything worse right um and so uh so
yeah we're pitching a client am i
supposed to do this now am i doing this
right we have a clip yeah so yeah so
we're pitching a new client on a new
product that she's got for a yogurt
water called cultured
let's take a look at publicity
i love it it's delicious
i like water but i want that sour taste
that like only yogurt can bring so what
can we do to help promote your product
um let's see oh i just had an amazing
idea what if we did an event liz i'm
sorry you are a genius i love you i love
you you're my best friend that's right
here's what i'm thinking we should do
cultured water is like very cultured and
like what is the most cultural thing oh
my god england london england oh my god
i love london england so it's like a
theme party all about london and glen
and culture water and then we can have
like a dell perform we should have a
delper for one i think it
you're awful
[Applause]
[Music]